you know I think jazz is the right
method for its freedom with inform you
know our new demographic research coming
out in July really shows that what Gen Y
wants and it's actually what boom is 12
is actually to stay with an employer
with the companies that they admire but
to mix and match to ebb and flow to have
much more of freedom with inform and to
have a long view one of the biggest
yearnings of these two you know
juggernaut generations and just remember
Gen Y says 80 million of them in the US
and only 37 million exes so this is a
huge you know generation on our doorstep
beginning to climb up the professional
ranks what they want within the context
of loyal attachment to an employer and
intense periods of work is Odyssey the
ability to search and quest the meaning
to maybe work for six weeks in Africa
and then you know absolutely get down to
you know work back on the ranch again
but I think that we are seeing a kind of
sea change in attitudes towards work and
a much more fluid and creative take on
what a you know 360 degree a full round
of a work experience you know should
look like obviously companies that
google or genzyme you know some of the
smaller innovative talent machines out
there are precisely allowing this but
there is a tension between loyalty and
quest I but it can be totally handled by
allowing you know this jazz like
arrangement and I think that's where
we're heading